Hi, I'm here again with Scott Murray.
And when you think about the future of data visualization what are you
most excited about?
>> Can I start with what I'm not excited about?
>> Yeah.
>> Not excited about more tools, more data.
That's like, usually I think what people are excited about, but
it's like every week some new tool gets announced.
And every week, you know, some government releases and some new data set and
like, it's all very good, but it can just be so
overwhelming, I think especially for people who are new.
>> Mm-hm. >> So I have to say, on one hand, I'm excited about that.
And on the other hand I'm like, not very excited about that.
I guess what I am excited about is having better resources for
new people, and, and having like all, so much excitement.
Like just, just getting these new people into the field.
because kind of like I was saying earlier,
like everybody brings their own experience, and it's been, you know?
I think visualization actually has this really long history, but
it's sort of because it's kind of blowing up in this whole new way just recently
like with this convergence of, of open data, and tools, and open source, and
all the sort of things you need to practice at getting more and more accessible.
Plus of course kind of the, the, the buzzwords of big data and
like all the stuff we're excited about.
So, all these things have converged to make this like a really hot
exciting field right now.
Which is great, but I think we forget that there's this whole history.
You know, of this field and that this, this history is related to kind of
representations of information before we started calling it data vis.
And it goes back to, to design and like how we evolved written language, and
you know, hieroglyphics and all this, all this stuff.
So I think, kind of in the, the early days in this new resurgence of
data visualization, practice was limited to kind of some academics, and
then a handful of, of really specialized design firms but now it's,
it's much, much bigger than that.
So we have lots of people.
We have people internal at companies who just do data vis for that company.
We have more and more of these kind of
boutique design firms that do kind of data design, data visualization.
We have existing firms like design firms,
graphic design who are getting into doing data.
And so, and then of course we have like students, and academics, and just kind
of people who don't fit into any of those categories who are practising.
So I think that's really really exciting, but it's also,
like I said, challenge for us because we have the existing books, and
resources, and things are great, but not totally adequate because they,
they address kind of different audiences in, in that vain.
Edward Tufte's books are fantastic, but, like he's a statistician, and
they're coming from this one point of view.
And I, I still recommend the books to everyone, but
they don't address all of the latest kind of developments in interactive design.
And, what does this mean translating these ideas to a mobile experience?
What does this mean translating this idea to a dashboard or a billboard, or
you know, something in advertisement?
So, there're all kinds of these new considerations, and
I guess I'm, I'm excited about us sort of together gradually figuring out
ways to address all those considerations.
>> What are you most excited about when you think about the future of
data visualization?
>> I think what we're most excited about at Plotley and
we think a lot about, is what it would be like to be able to have massive,
worldwide collaboration in doing data analysis and graphing?
And so, a big part of what we thought about for
Plotley, is making everything web-ready.
So, if you already know, let's say,
MatLab, or you're really good at using Excel, we don't think that
it makes a lot of sense for you to also have to learn how to do web development.
So we've tried to make it so it's really easy to keep using the tools that
you're using, but then being able to get a web and
collaboration layer for sharing your work with people from any language
who are using any different type of technology, any different data type.
And so it can really kind of be a translation layer, because if you have
really sophisticated, let's say, political scientists, and engineers, and
data scientists, who are all able to collaborate between their respective
preferred development languages, and tools, and able to discuss things, and
make reproducible graphs, and data, and work on massive research projects.
We really hope that it would be able to further, you know,
science and collaboration in really any field.
You know, so we've thought about what if folks from NASA
were streaming flight data and showing live satellite data.
What if groups that were doing research on cancer were able to share their resu,
results with the world, so
anyone can reproduce their work and get involved with what they're doing?
So experts can collaborate naturally even if they didn't necessarily plan to do
so from the beginning.
Because if you make data, and if you make graphs, and you make tools available,
and free, and easy to use, we think there's a lot of power behind that.